so you started making this and it was
really for yourself and then you started
selling it how quickly did you realize
there were gonna be some legal issues
even in California where it is legal oh
well right away right away I mean you
know there's still such a problem with
perception first of all so okay
California was the first to allow for
medical marijuana it's been that way for
about 20 years but beyond doing that
there really aren't any regulations
established so it's like the Wild West
or it has been like that and there are a
lot of people who want to do the right
thing
want to operate in a safe way
but without guidelines without
regulations you can't really do that and
you know there because of the perception
problem because of the stigma problem
and and because there are no clear laws
dispensaries are still being attacked
closed down shut down and so literally I
mean you're not making the dispensaries
in California there was a dispensary
maybe five blocks away from me that
about six months ago was closed down it
was legal within the California set of
laws but federally because it's not
legal the feds pretty much at any time
could come in and stop you right right
look I'm at risk right and leave no fans
watch yeah but in and it's not even just
it's not that the I mean I guess that is
the case in some instances that the feds
do come in and shut them down but even
local you know municipalities are going
in and shutting down places because
they're using them land use codes to
evict people and threaten their
landlords and shut places down yeah so
how do you operate knowing that that's
sort of out there it's a very precarious
position
well first of all I it's a business but
for me it's primarily a passion project
you know I do this because it means a
lot to me to be in the industry and to
help change he'll help help change
perspectives on it i I know that well I
believe that a lot of people who are
anti marijuana are really just
misinformed you know there's been a lot
of negative propaganda and it's going to
take some time to get good real
information out to people yeah this is
sort of like for people that are pro
marijuana even not even recreational but
even medicinally this is sort of the
fault of you've had the government which
scared people about how on all right you
can think of those just those posters in
the 60s you know just like making
everyone look evil smoking weed and then
even the Hollywood side of things
Hollywood which is obviously very
liberal and proud generally but every
movie related to pot is just a bunch of
goofballs doing ridiculous things so it
makes it seem like it's gonna make you
dumb or stupid or something of that
there's really nothing in between those
two places which is well I guess this is
this is between those two places you'd
be surprised at how many of us really
fall in between most people are the
extremes it's just that people are
afraid to come out and rightly so
because because it is still federally
illegal and and there is still this
stigma attached to it when I was working
full time and in the corporate world I
definitely kept my youth private because
I didn't want to be judged
um it's I didn't feel ashamed but I
didn't want anyone to use that
information against me and I I think
that that a lot of people fall into that
category and it's a shame because it
it's so easy to keep those stereotypes
going of the potheads donor
you know it's easy to to dismiss the
whole industry if that's all you have in
your head when you think about it but
there's so much more to it than that
yeah I'm so fascinated by that because
you know I've talked about you know gay
people coming out they're not trying to
push anyone else in gay there's coming
out for themselves exactly I've talked
about this related to atheists because I
get emails all the time where atheists
even in Western societies where it's
okay to be atheist will say I'm afraid
of coming out because it might have an
effect on my job or my parents or my
cousin or something like that and now I
never thought of it really in the
context of marijuana but yeah it's a
professional person you didn't want to
be seen a certain way so how did you
remove that Sigma I mean did you go home
to your parents and say I'm gonna yes
once I decided that this was important
and this is what I wanted to do I
definitely made a shift to to being out
and I told my parents you know and this
is what I'm doing I use cannabis for my
migraines I use cannabis you know I I'm
still a good mother
you know productive member of society I
mean not that they question me but but
you felt it was like sort of on you to
sell your case in a way oh yes yes and
it's interesting you know there's still
even though they know what I do is is
good they believe that I'm providing a
good but there's you know they worry
they worry but they they see how the
laws are and see how you know there's a
risk yeah yeah so one of the laws that I
simply cannot believe is this section
one thing right so this is that the
federal government basically says at
this point that marijuana has no medical
than
right there's a good jillion studies
that show that's not true there are a
zillion examples of people like yourself
that show that that's not true I've
smoked weed after hurting my knee
playing basketball and felt that air so
you know most people know that this
isn't true but this is the Obama
administration that still is backing
this so when these dispensaries are
closed here in California where again it
is legal this is coming from Obama who's
pretty good on weed so it's so complex
yes I'd hoped for more change you know I
did read the other day who knows of this
is true that Gary Johnson predicted that
Obama would was it reclassify or
declassify it on his way out and you
know that's kind of a Schedule one by
the way yes yeah so that would be
amazing if he did that yeah it's I had
Gary Johnson on the show and I mean a
libertarian as I was saying at the top a
libertarian should be the most Pro weed
person there is this is you and your
life right you're not pushing it on kids
you're doing something that makes you
feel bad
yeah I think the problem is just this
it's been this way for so long it's hard
to change course especially when you're
going pretty much 180 you know yeah I
mean to have cannabis on the schedule
one it has led to so many people
suffering needlessly you know being put
in prison having criminal records that
affect the rest of their lives and
what's horrifying about it is that it's
it impacts communities of color more so
this whole war on drugs is a failure and
it it's been used as a way to target
certain communities yeah and I think
just this week there was something that
came out that one of Nixon's advisors
has now admitted yeah part of what they
did
related to criminalizing certain drugs
was purposely aimed at minority
communities you're not just picking up
some exactly here's fact yes I read that
same thing he admitted it was the
hippies and and the african-americans
that that they wanted to be able to go
into those communicate communities
arrest their leaders raid their homes
with that was the goal and here we are
it's it's it's still happening it's
still happening and so I think we're
asking people you know law enforcement
to give up control of this and you know
there are a lot of law enforcement that
that believe that's for the best but
there's still resistance because it's
the way we've operated for so many years
right so basically if you're a business
owner like yourself or someone added
dispensary or just somebody that likes
weed if you want this thing to flip as
quickly as possible basically you want
pretty much a lawsuit to get involved
where a dispensary is shut down and that
case has to get up to the Supreme Court
right like is that where you see that
ultimately the only way we're gonna stop
this
federally is through the Supreme Court
right I I don't know I mean you know I
just read something that I think was
normal issued it about how that's
probably not the fastest track you know
it's really more of a state's issue and
in the more states that that legalized
it then then the feds will just kind of
give us will follow hopefully you know
Bernie Sanders said he would descale it
yeah
Hillary Clinton said she'd move it to
schedule two but you know what for
California at least I can speak to that
a little bit I mean that's what the LA
medical cannabis taskforce is trying to
accomplish here locally you know
California is like forty nine percent of
the national market when it comes to
cannabis and LA is is the center of all
of that for us to not have common-sense
regulations for this industry
ridiculous you know we all know it's
here yeah you know the majority of la
residents want it here so how are we
going to provide access to people I'm
not just part of it that it's hard to
motivate people that smoke pot you know
you mean like I was trying at the top of
trying to say you know I'm not but it's
hard to have this conversation without
saying things that sound silly like that
but there's some level of that right
like I can think of my four years of
college when I sat on a couch stoned but
if you had told me if I would just go
next door we could legalize it I
probably wouldn't have got up you know
yeah well you know what I think it's
more fear that that has stopped the
community from coming together because
when you know that you could get busted
at any time it's hard to form alliances
you know it's it promotes everyone
having a you know a mentality of being
just out for themselves you know that's
the way it's been people operating kind
of in the shadows because they don't
want to draw too much attention to
themselves because who knows what's
gonna happen next week you know but
that's what the task force is trying to
accomplish is you know the state of
California recently passed some laws
that went into effect the beginning of
this year the mersa medical marijuana
regulation and Safety Act which creates
a path for legitimacy and and licensure
for everyone that's in this industry but
it's up to all the city you know the
cities to to then enact regulations that
comply with that right so la does have
an opportunity now and that's what we're
hoping to accomplish is to get some
regulations on the books that really
encourages this industry I mean we we
want it here you know so what should
that look like what's the how do we need
to make that happen
yeah it's so interesting because it's so
much reminds me of the fossil fuel
versus green energy argument because
obviously like the fossil fuel lobbyists
big pharmacy has a lot of lobbyists
right they're all paying all the
politicians to basically
keep weed illegal at some level keep
cannabis illegal because they are trying
to sell a lot of pills and it sort of
goes back to where you started with
about creating a garden and a life that
you could grow something out of the
earth that could take care of some of
your problems and yet we're so afraid of
that we'd rather them handed to us in
pill form and then at the same time half
the commercial for that pill tells you
worse things than you had to take them
out for in the first place side effects
may include yeah doing is they should
have to show those people having those
side effects they should show someone
vomiting and on the toilet I have a
diarrhea and thoughts but how much of
that is just related to politics that
the pharmaceutical companies don't want
this to happen so I think that is a big
part of it I mean the way things are
benefits a lot of people those people
don't want to see things change because
that takes money out of their pockets
and it's it's pretty simple yeah but for
me you know it's it's not about getting
rich for me it's about simplifying like
I said and you know I would love to just
be as self-sufficient as possible I mean
to grow my own food to grow my own
medicine you know to compost to to you
know to not have to go to a store for
everything that I need I mean that
that's kind of the default mentality you
know you need something you go out and
buy it you you use something you're done
with it you throw it away and we're so
disconnected from nature from what we're
doing to the environment you know it's
so easy to to not think about that and
for me cannabis is an important part of
taking care of myself you know in a way
that you know you know I
it it helps me in so many ways I don't
need to go to a doctor to get it no yeah
it's yeah
would you see those guys you know if you
walk down Venice Boulevard right on the
strip there we've got the guys all
dressed in green and they're the 420
doctors they got a hat on with a weed
leaf and all that do you think that
actually is doing some of the reverse
effects because then people are like
this seems so silly yeah I think so I I
see a lot of tourists taking pictures of
those yeah exactly so it's it's um you
know it's it's a spectacle I guess
that's me mostly what they're going for
I think down there at on Venice Beach
yeah but I do think it points out kind
of the the that that there isn't really
that much of a difference you know
between in my mind between medicinal and
recreational right you know and yes you
have to get a recommendation from a
physician to get it in California yes
it's pretty easy to do that right have
there been any I mean everything that
I've read about what's going on in
Colorado right now I'd say 90% of it has
been very good basically they're
bringing in a lot more tax revenue right
it's I don't I haven't seen anything
about crime suddenly going up or
suddenly other spikes and other drug use
you know they always say marijuana is a
gateway drug what do you say to that
people say that I can't wait to what
that's that's what I wonder about you
know I mean okay so I've I've used
cannabis for many years and I I don't
like to drink alcohol I can occasionally
but it makes me sneeze
you know I get really congested and I
just don't really enjoy it yeah so and
you know I think there's been research
that shows that you know a lot of people
that can use drugs
and not get addicted you know addiction
is a problem but to say that just
because I smoke cannabis I'm I'm you
know headed down this road where you
know there's I'll never come back it's
it's silly
well I always I remember thinking how
crazy it was the way they've demonized
weed because when I said it to stop the
tried never smoking until I was a
sophomore in college I remember smoking
weed and then laughing or whatever
whatever went on and I were thinking
wait a minute they've told me weed is so
horrible so what about these other drugs
so in a weird way by demonizing weed a
marijuana and cannabis whatever we're
calling it now they actually have
convinced a lot of people I think to try
other drugs because then you try weed
you know this isn't so bad well what
about crack yeah I understand yeah cuz
it's so clearly misinformation you know
and people aren't stupid you know so
yeah it does send the wrong message yeah
what do you think about how I noticed
that a lot of my friends who used to be
huge huge pot heads either don't smoke
anymore or barely ever smoke or when
they do they eat only need the tiniest
puffs as I said at the top I spoke at
this point maybe once a month I take one
puff a granddaddy purple you know the
grande yes yeah which is an indica
because I told the guy I just want to
melt into the couch and watch TV and
that's it and I really it's once a month
one pop I'm good to go
but something about weed is different
than other drugs because people that use
it a lot of seem to I think George
Carlin did a bit about this they seem to
not grow out of it necessarily but it
has a reverse addictive thing in some
ways you know doing some people because
for the people that get paranoid list
right they say well I don't want that
anymore and I think you would probably
say well that maybe try an indica more
than a sativa right well yeah what's
interesting is okay so they've found
that your body has an endocannabinoid
system right so there are receptors in
your brain and all through your body
that are there to accept cannabinoids
you're you you produce cannabinoids in
your own body you know it's in breath
smell
so they've found that what cannabis does
is just it affects your ended
cannabinoid system which then brings
your body into balance and that's why it
helps with so many ailments and that's
why for many years people couldn't
believe that it helped with so many
things how could it do this and this and
this and this
no no drug does that yeah it's because
you have this built-in regulation system
in the endocannabinoid system and
cannabis helps bring your bring that
into balance so it kind of does make
sense that if you're using it you know
and that after its amount a certain
amount of time maybe you need to use
less
yes--it's which is such an interesting
thing about a drug right that you know
you think you need what you do it more
you're gonna need more right and in a
lot of ways I know that that so exists
at some level with marijuana that some
of my friends you know they need to
smoke more because it doesn't hit them
the way it used to or they'll change
strain or something right but a lot of
people eventually either need much less
or have much less of a desire amantha
that doesn't fit any of the definitions
of what addiction and drugs are normally
with addiction you have to keep upping
the dosage upping the dosage and you
know like for when I use when I have an
edible cookie at night I mean that's
twelve thirteen milligrams and that's
plenty for me yeah and that may not be
migraine related that might just be just
to to as a sleep aid you know or if I'm
feeling like it helps if your muscles
are sore you know just as relaxes you
but 12 milligrams is not a lot and you
know if if it were you know if that were
true addiction and and having to have
more and more I mean I would be eating
more more cookies you know and it's one
is fine right now these are all carb
free right oh yeah